Než začnu.
Tak bych chtěl vysvětlit, co bude v příštích pár dnech.
Takže ten kurz skončí po snídaní sobotu.
Takže se zpátek musíme začít trošku jako
schladit se musíme.
Takže myslím, že ten přísný režim skončí asi v pátek odpoledne.
V pátek ráno patrně zakončím
A pátek odpoledne budu dělat moje speciální cvičení New Age.
Léčbu.
Potom budeme mít nějakou dokončenou cvičení
Takže tohle byl takový malý úvodní obřad.
Závědeční obřad.
Závědeční.
Že dělat závědč, že je to pátek.
A pak budeme mít otázky a odpovědi.
Takže otázky stále přinášejte.
A jestliže bude nějaká otázka, která se týká přímo meditace, tak ji odpovíme če.
Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sambha sambuddhasa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sambha sambuddhasa
Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sambha sambhudassa Homage to the blessed, noble and fully self-enlightened one.
Before I give some explanation of karma, předtím než vysvětlím karmu,
Chtěl bych si něco vyjasnit.
Zdá se, že existuje jakési zmatení ohledně pojmu duchovní, spirituální.
Takže já si snažím používat slova, která buddhistické učení nemíchají s Freudem.
Takže nechci používat slova jako ego a tak.
Takže já si snažím používat slovo pro...
najít slovo pro mysl a srdce.
Ve východních kulturách, a myslím, že obzvláště v Tajsku, existuje jen jedno slovo pro mysl a srdce.
A když oni přemýšlí, tak si nemyslí, že by to šlo
více odsud než odsud.
Řekové měli taky tuto myšlenku.
Lidská bytost se skládala ze tří částí.
Soma, tedy tělo.
Psychika, tedy mysl a srdce.
A pneuma, tedy duch.
Toto bylo přebráno křesťanskou filozofií.
A v latině je to Corpus Animus Spiritus.
V angličtině, a já jsem si jistý, že máte české slova, říkáme body, mind a spiritus.
A tedy v češtině říkáme tělo, mysl a duch.
Problemem je, že v naší kultuře skrze Descartovou filozofii on oddělil emoce od myšlenek.
Takže teď myslíme, že všechno se děje tady.
Takže si nesmyslíme, že všechno se děje tady, v hlavě.
A co my v meditaci zjistíme, že všechno v podstatě začíná tady v srdci.
Začne to takovým druhém touhy,
buď radostné nebo úzkostné, která hledá nějaký předmět.
Takže když slunce vyjde, tak se radost tak nějak radost působí, že bude hezký den.
Uchopí hezký den.
A depresa řekne, že je příliš horko.
Takže v buddhistickém učení máme stejnou věc.
Slovo čita může být představováno velmi jasně jako psyche.
může být vcelku jasně přeložená jako psychika.
Tedy kombinace mysli a srdce.
Takže když jsem včera říkal, že
Budha řekl, že můžete vytáhnout mysl z těla jako meč z pochvy.
Tak tady nešlo o duchovní věc.
Pořád tady jde o svět fenoménů.
Svět fenoménů.
To je jemnohmotné tělo.
V textech známe jako čita tělo.
Trpí stejnými charakteristikami jako tělesné tělo, fyzické tělo.
Vystává a zase odchází.
Je to komponováno, vytvořeno,
je složené z různých energí.
A není žádnou entitou, není tím já.
Takže když porozumíme tomu, nebo když řekneme, že já jsem pochopil, že nejsem tím tělem, když tělo zemře,
Musíme také mít možnost říct, že nejsem emoce, protože emoce umírají více rychleji.
A já nemohu být myšlenkou, protože myšlenky přijímají dokonce rychleji.
Jakou emocií chci být?
Tak jakou emocií chci být, jakou myšlenkou jsem?
Tak co nám meditace přináší, je, že
Že nám začíná ukazovat, že ty různé části, které vytváří lidskou bytost, tělo se všemi svými orgány, játrami, žaludkem, hlavou, sádnost, ráno,
Srdce se všemi svými emocemi, smutkem, štěstím.
A mysl se vším svým vnímáním a obrazy a představami.
Nemůže vytvořit žádnou entitu.
Já.
Osobu.
To je způsob, jakým conceptualizujeme nás sami.
Když se podíváte na strom, vypadá jako jeden předmět, jeden objekt, strom.
Ale víme, že přitom je vytvořen z jednotlivých listů, větví, pořenů a tak.
A když se začneme na člověka dívat takovýmto způsobem,
začneme uvědomovat, co je to, co je pozorováno.
Co je to, co pozorujete.
Co porozuje.
Co je to, co pozoruje.
Proto se nás Buda požádal, že vše, co zakoušíme,
jako vznikající a zemkající, ne já.
A my začínáme porozumět tomu, jaká kvalita je v tomto poznání.
Když tyto kvality toho poznání nám začnou být zřejmé, tak to jsou duchovní pravdy.
Budha na to poukazuje různými citacemi.
Jeho nejznámější citace je, když nám řekl, co není.
Takže říká, že existuje, existuje, existuje, existuje, existuje, existuje.
Co to znamená?
Tam existuje.
Takže v Páli existují dvě slova pro je.
Existují dvě slova pro je.
Jedna je, co říkáme, jen jednoduchá vzpomínka.
Jedno je, co my nazýváme běžnou spojkou.
Řeknu, toto je miska.
Tak to je, nemá význam.
Řekl bych, toto je miska, abyste rozuměli.
Je významný, je významný.
Now, the other word is, the other word that he uses here
A to druhé slovo, který zde použil, je existuje, existovat.
Zde existuje nezrozené.
Neumírající.
Nesložené.
a nepodmíněné.
A on řekl, kdyby zde toto nebylo, tak by zde nebylo úniku ze zrození a smrti, ze složenosti a podmíněnosti.
Takže to je to, co musíme objevit, to nezrozené, neumírající.
A toto můžeme říct, že je právě zkušeností Nirvány.
Používám zde slovo Nirvána jako takový záblesk pravdy.
Když se staneme pozorovatelem, řekněme, nějaké emoce, a díváme se na to, jako kdyby to bylo ne já, tak kde je utrpení?
Ano.
On také řekl něco, co nám dává velmi pozitivní představu.
Ale musím vás zvadovat, že to je citát, který terravádová tradice nemá ráda.
A terravádová tradice to miluje.
Překlad z ní je, že existuje vědomí.
Nezbarvené šesti smysly.
To jsou pěti běžnými smysly a pak myslí a srdce.
Takže existuje vědomí
kde není žádný zrák, čich a žádná myšlenka.
Bez hranic.
A teď můžete mít hranice jenom pokud máte fenomény.
a ve všech směrech plno světla.
Probuzenost.
Tak tohle tomu řeknu, víte.
Všechno, tohle je... Psychology?
And physiology, the body.
Before you say it.
To je spirituální, ale všechno, to jediné, ten zážitek, je spirituální a tam to ostatní, to je prostě tělo, emoce a psychologie a tak.
To je všechno.
Takže doufám, že to vyjasnilo všechny zmatky ohledně slov, které jsem včera používal.
Takže teď bych chtěl říct něco o karmi.
Takže byste měli jasnou představu, co tím Budha myslel.
samozřejmě, že existuje takové lidové, lidový porozumění tohoto jméno a duchovní porozumění.
Takže první věc je, že v buddhistické tradici jsou pět věcí z univerzu.
Existuje pět zákonů vesmíru.
První je stejný, jako je naše fyzika, chemie a tak.
Jinými slovy materiální svět.
Je známe jako uttu, což je v podstatě fire element.
V jiných řečech, materiální energie vesmíru.
Já bych to úplně nestrovával se současnou vědou.
Trošku to připomíná ty subatomární částice.
Ale prostě šlo o představu, že celý ten vesmír je založen na té energii ohně.
Oheň samozřejmě zde je metaforou.
A myslím, že jsem správný v tom, že tohle bylo všechno příroda, i řekové to věděli.
Nyní, fyzický svět je celkem, největší části, nepředstavující.
Fyzikální svět je z velké části nepředvídatelný.
Můžeme třeba si představit bouře, které přicházejí.
Zemětřesení, které lidi rozmačkají k smrti.
Meteory, které přichází z vesmíru a zničí třeba celý život na Zemi.
To bylo třeba před pár milionů let.
Z našeho pohledu, lidských bytostí, to způsobuje velké utrpení.
Ale zasloužíme si to?
Když vás to přimáčkne při zemětřesení, znamená to, že jste v nějakém minulém životě stoupli úmyslně na tisíc mravenců?
Kdyby jste plavili v moře, představte si, že plavíte v moře a teď vás strhne prout a utopíte se.
Znamená to, že jste v minulém životě utopili vaše ština?
Neskutečně dostanete takový argument od tradičních buddhistů.
Bohužel, ten druh argumentace najdete v tradičním buddhismu.
Už jsem vám říkal ten příběh o lodi, která se zastaví na oceáně z ničehož nic?
je v jednom z příběhů, který týkajících se textů.
Takže bychom to neměli mýchat s učením Budhy.
Ale loď náhle zastavila uprostřed oceánu.
The captain and the crew were completely mystified.
Luckily there was a group of monks on board.
So they asked the monks to meditate and find out why this was happening.
tak oni požádali mníchy, aby meditovali a přišli na to, proč se to stalo.
Jíši se pohroužili do hlubokého soustředění a přišli s odpovědí.
Bylo to kůly kapitánově ženě.
Ve svém minulém životě totiž utopila příliš mnoho psů.
Jediný způsob, jak může loď pokračovat v plavbě, museli hodit tu ženu přes palubu.
Tak oni hodili přes palubu a loď pokračovala v plavbě.
Tak jak vidíte, kolem karmy může být spousta nejasností z matků.
Další zákon je zákonem něčeho, co bychom nazvali genetikou.
Slovo, které je zde použito, je bíža.
To znamená síd.
Znamená to semínko.
Tak a teď o tom přemýšlejte.
Tělo, v kterém se narodíme, se k nám dostalo skrze generace rodičů.
Skrze generace zvířat.
Všude do prostě zvířat.
Až úplně k jednoduchému čarbovi.
Všechno ta samá genetická linie.
Takže stěží si můžeme tuto tělo nějak zasloužit.
Prostě jsme to dostali.
A teď představte si, že někdo se narodí s genetickou vadou.
Je to proto, že v minulém životě oni někoho zabili?
Nebo mučili?
Nebo udělali něco hrozného?
Nemůžete to říct?
Pro mě to by bylo hrozný věc,
Pro mě by to bylo hrozný tohleto říct.
Je zcela zřejmé, že tělo je výsledkem mnoha různých příčin.
Jestliže máme věřit v buddhistické
a buddhistickému učení o tom, jak se člověk rodí, je všeobecně rozuměno, že v momentě, kdy je vajíčko oplodněno, jakmile dojde k početí,
Tato psychika vstupuje do tohoto zárodku.
To je takové všeobecně pojímáno.
Takže
Tělo přišlo z této strany a ta mysl, která se má znovu zrodit, z této strany.
A samozřejmě musíte být opatrní ohledně současných vědeckých poznatků, protože
Jednou vám dokážou říct, že podle experimentů ryba nemůže cítit bolest.
A o pár týdnů později vám řeknou, že mají experimenty, které potvrzují, že ryba může cítit bolest.
Věci se mi zdají stejně zmatení jako kdokoliv jiný.
Ale když budeme věřit tomu malému průzkoumání, to by bylo, že když se děti stávají fátní,
tak by pak se zdálo, že když rodič stloustne, tak by to mělo ovlivnit geny tak, že už vnoučata by měli mít sklon k tlouštce.
Takže bychom mohli říct,
A tak můžeme říct, bychom mohli říct, že když se narodí člověk s genetickou vadou, tak by to mohlo být kvůli špatnému chování nějakých minulých rodičů,
A nebo genetickou mutací, která se nepovedla.
Kdo ví?
Ale otázkou je, zaslouží si takový člověk se narodit, řekněme, v...
bolestivém těle když jsem pobýval v plášteře zvaný Amorati blízko Londýna někteří jste možná potkali sestru Chandasiri která tady byla tak ona tam žije taky pobýval jsem tam rok
A během toho roku přicházel mladík, který trpěl progresivní genetickou vadru.
Když jsem se s ním setkal, byl téměř paralizován a všechny jeho...
končitiny byly takhle ohnuté.
Museli jsme ho všude nosit.
Byl to velmi šťastný člověk.
On zcela přijímul svůj stav.
Velmi ho zajímal duchovný život.
A všichni ho měli velmi rádi.
Když jsme byli dotázáni, kdo by rád strávil večer s, nevím, jak se jmenoval, řekněme, s Johnem,
a byla radost s ním pobývat.
Doktoři řekli jeho rodičům, že to bude šance tak jednak k mnoha milionům, když jeho další dítě bude být taky.
aby příští děcko trpělo stejnou vadu.
A oni měli ještě dceru.
Ale bohužel u ní se vyvinula úplně stejná vada.
A podle toho, co jsem slyšel, protože já jsem se s ní nikdy nesetkal, byla byla týnečná.
byla nějak takovou dospívající.
A byla velmi jaksi rozlobená.
Stejná nemoc, ale úplně jiný stav mysli.
Tak kde je karma?
nemůžeme říct, že tělo, s kterým skončíme, je kvůli naší osobní karmě.
Když jsme vytvořeni do času a místa,
když se zrodíme do nějakého času a místa, jsou nám dany určité podmínky, které nemůžeme nijak ovlivnit.
Rodiče, tělo, společnost, jazyk, země, kultura, historie, jídlo,
Někteří lidé říkají, jestli vás zajímá jídlo, neměli byste se narodit v Anglii.
Ale už se to lepší.
A další věc na světě je Čitta.
Dalším zákonem smíru je čita.
A my bychom to přeložili jako naše psychologie.
A my zde mluvíme o základním způsobu, jakým zakoušíme život.
Tedy naše vnímání, způsob, jakým můžeme věci nahlížet,
náš emoční život.
A jak víme z naší psychologie, toto je velmi komplikované a velmi velmi velmi velmi velmi velmi velmi velmi velmi velmi velmi velmi velmi velmi velmi velmi velmi
Budhův vlastní specifický zájem je psychologie kolem utrpení.
Můžeme říct, že když se
veškerá lidská mysl spojí, aby vytvořila společnost, tak všechno zde je vytvořeno z mysli.
Nic, co by bylo člověkem vytvořené, zde není vytvořeno
Ať už je to chleba, jet plane, mp3 přehrávač, to začalo v někoho způsobu.
Všechno to začalo v někoho v hlavě.
Knihy, které čteme, televize, hudba, to vše začíná v hlavě.
Takže, vzpomínaný v mysli, můžeme to vzpomínat na celou naši společnost.
Začínáme s ideí mysli,
A tuto představu té mysli můžeme rozšířit na celou společnost, na mysl celé společnosti.
A vy jste narozeni v určité konkrétní skupině myslí, která je vaší kulturou.
Můžete být trochu šťastní.
Já jsem se narodil italské matce v Itálii.
Ale skončil jsem v Británii.
Takže tohle je třetí lov, lov psychologie.
Tak to je třetí zákon, zákon psychologie.
Nebo zákon psychiky, mysli a srdce.
Tak a teď konečně přicházíme k zákonu karmy.
A toto má obzvláště co dočínění s naším etickým morálním životem.
A je to pevně propojenost kolem závislého vznikání.
Včera jsme řekli,
A proto jsme udělali chybu.
A proto děláme chybu.
Řečeno v širším toho smyslu, je to proto, že jsme lidské bytosti.
Myslíme si, že musíme vytvořit dokonalé štěstí v tomto světě.
A proto vstupujeme do úpívání.
Takové jako chamtivosti, chtivosti.
Jsme v konfliktu s čímkoliv, co nechceme.
A samozřejmě utíkáme od čehokoliv, co nahlížíme jako nebezpečné.
Tak toto je naše karma.
Toto je to, co Bůh myslel karmou.
Now this then translates these attitudes translate into actions.
You can think as greedy as you want, but when you actually take something, then you reinforce that conditioning.
tak posilujete toto podmiňování.
Tak řekněme, že jste vykradli banku.
A byli jste nechyceni.
Tak šli jste do vězení.
A v českém buddhismě
běžného buddhistu, je skutečnost, že jdete do vězení vaší karmou.
Ale co když jste šťastní ve vězení?
To by předpokládalo, že budete šťastní ve vězení.
Že...
Jsou lidé, kteří byli ve vězení tak dlouho, že dávají přednost tomu ve vězení zůstat, než aby z něho odešli.
Máte svůj vlastní pokoj, jídlo se servíruje, můžete číst knihy, sledovat televizu
Spousta společníků.
A je to pravda, někteří vězni se takto institucionalizovali.
A je to pravda, že někteří vězni se takto institucionalizovali.
A někteří vězni, když byli propuštěni, tak úmyslně udělali nějaký zločin, aby se mohli vrátit.
Takže jít do vězení není z budhova pohledu karmou.
Je to mentální stav,
který vystává, když jste chycení.
Bolest ze ztráty osobní svobody.
Takže znovu, karma, o které mluví buddhisté, takže vzpomněte si, je to karma osvobození, je vždy výborný.
Je vždy uvnitř.
Tak to je opravdové porozumění karmě.
A někdy samozřejmě svět může být nespravedlivý.
Myslím se například o americkém společenství v Palestíně.
Mám na mysli například všechny ty americké mírové jednotky v Palestíně?
Jo, jeden američan v Palestíně.
Možná se to viděli v televizi.
Který byl zabit izraelským buldozerem.
Takže je to
Takže proto, že děláte dobro, ještě neznamená, že k vám dobro bude i přicházet.
Ve skutečnosti byste spíš měli očekávat opak.
Gandhi byl zastřelen.
Martin Luther King byl zastřelen.
Ježíš byl křižován.
Takže nikdy nevíte, vidíte?
Nikdy nevíte.
Když jsem byl na Sříglance, zeptal jsem se jednoho Sříglančana, který byl buddhistou.
Říkal jsem mu, proč si myslíš,
Zeptal jsem se ho, proč si myslí, že byl Ježíš Kristus ukřižován.
On řekl, on musel provést něco strašného ve své minulém životě.
Něco hrosného.
Takže jestli chcete vědět o buddhismu, nezapomeňte buddhistům.
A konečně je tu pátý zákon, který je duchovním zákonem, zákonem dhamy.
A doufáme, že toto je to, o čem tady při tomhle kurzu jde.
Tak tohle byl takový úvod do karmy.
A doufám, že jste získali tu esenci hovčení.
A když se věříte o tom, co přijde,
A jestliže se objeví nějaká otázka týkající se tohohle, tak je tam vložte dost těch sklenic.
A v pátek večer všechno bude vyjevené.
Takže, děkujeme velmi moc.
Takže, jestli uděláte nějakou první meditaci,
Víte, víte, víte, víte, víte, víte, víte, víte, víte.